remember the night okay I had broken up
I was dating this guy who was the
classic like He's Just Not That Into You
guy like everything I did it just I was
all in and he wasn't so Sam was like
listen we're taking you for drinks and I
was like thank you so I show up in my
leather gloves I got all dressed up cuz
I wanted to feel good about myself and I
showed up for drinks with you and Justin
yeah and that's the night I fell in love
with Justin
yeah yeah we love Justin he's the best
him he comes on the show Kate comes on
the show they're the best couple they
are best couple oh they're so good for
each other they're beautiful couple
they're so right for each other they are
they are they really they're really a
great couple yeah she's a sweetheart